so I know this is probably a huge cliche
since probably everything every single
speaker says this but it's a huge honor
to be here I was sitting in your seats
about 10 years ago which seems like not
that long and yet quite a long time we
just celebrated our my class class of oh
six just celebrate our 10-year reunion
here like a couple months ago which is a
lot of fun so it's really really great
to be here I remember when I was sitting
in your seats and you know I had just
come from Texas that's where I was
raised and you know I've done some web
design in the past but I didn't really
know anything about Silicon Valley know
anything about you know this kind of
tech hub and what it means to like have
a career here and startups and all of
that prior to coming to Stanford and I
remember you know sitting in the
audience and listening to the stories of
people who had kind of come before me
and in particular you know Marissa Meyer
and Jen Fitzpatrick and they'd stand up
here and they would talk about kind of
their adventures after leaving Stanford
and all of the great things that they
got to go and build and work on and I
was just like wow this is super super
exciting and you know now I'm excited to
be here talking to all of you guys and
hopefully sharing a couple of fun
stories along the way so you know as you
guys heard I was here I did my computer
science degree my bachelor's and my
master's and I was also lucky enough to
be a part of the Mayfield Fellows
Program so how many guys know about the
Mayfield Fellows Program chance okay so
for those of you who don't know you know
this is an awesome program that that is
really about diving into
entrepreneurship and so one part of the
program is that between you know your
junior your senior year you go and get
an internship with a start-up somewhere
in the valley and you know along the way
we are as we're interning at our
respective companies we're learning
about entrepreneurship we're taking
classes we're doing case studies and
it's fabulous it's it's awesome stop by
Tina I had a lot of fun doing it so at
the time of the startup that I chose was
actually Facebook
and you know this is a little bit of a
little little cheating because in 2006
Facebook was already about a hundred
people so it was a startup but on the
larger end of a start-up and you know
but it was something I was really
excited to work on because it was a
product that I and all of my classmates
at the time you know used very
religiously so I went there and I
remember my first day at Facebook in
fact I was signed up to be an engineer
and work on you know some of their
photos features and I had a mentor and
her name was Ruchi and on the first day
she said okay there's been a change of
plans I'm switching jobs I'm not going
to be engineer anymore I'm gonna be a PM
I don't really know what that means for
you but let me you know introduce you to
this pod of people over here you know
this is our design team why don't you
sit with them and you know like chat
with them I've got to go run and so she
left me in this pod with this group of
designers and before that you know I I'm
not a designer by trade I didn't really
know anything about design but I got to
talking to these people and you know I
sat at that pod and lo and behold you
know fast forward ten years and now you
know my careers in design and when I
look back on it it sort of seems really
quite random how it happened but for me
what was so exciting about design was
the the chance to work at the forefront
and thinking about you know what are the
people who are going through the
experience that were building what are
they feeling what are they thinking you
know how are they able to understand the
products that we built and so to me that
was what was super super fascinating
about design and also wasn't that crazy
because at the time you know the
designers that we hired were also our
front-end engineering team so it's a
little bit of both designing and a
little bit of coding this back in the
world where you know we were still
operating with just websites so you just
had to you know do some CSS and
JavaScript and front-end PHP and it
wasn't nearly as complicated of an
ecosystem as it is today but we got to
building and one of the first things I
worked on was of photos and photo
products
I also remember one of my first big
launches a couple months later which was
newsfeed
back in September of 2006 over the years
I've worked on things like the Facebook
platform and ushering in a bunch of
applications built on top of Facebook
including you know a lot of games back
in the era of 2008 and 2009 I worked on
profile and timeline and I worked on
newsfeed and today the team that I lead
we work on design for all of the core
features of the Facebook application so
when you go on Facebook and you want to
catch up with your friends you want to
share you want to you know watch videos
or you know join a group those are a lot
of the things that my my team works on
so all that said that's a little bit of
a intro into kind of how I got here the
thing that I think has been the most
fascinating for me as I've you know
looked back on all the things that I've
worked on is you know the moment when
you're starting a project and you're
thinking about you know here's this
awesome new idea that I have and I can
imagine you know how it's going to work
and how people are going to use it and I
want to build it right now and you know
you rally
a bunch of other people together with
you and you guys are all excited about
this idea that's how everything happens
right that's how any idea ever sees the
light of day but the question that I
found super fascinating is how do we
know at that point in time whether this
is an idea that's going to be successful
how do we know at you know it's all said
done and we've worked our nights and
weekend and we've gotten it out to the
world it will it actually be something
that people find valuable and that
they'll find easy to use and that
they'll find well-crafted
and you know being at Facebook we've had
our share of features some of them that
have gone on to be great success and
some of them that haven't and a lot of
times at the beginning you know there's
there's it feels like there's really no
way to tell feels like you're you're
kind of rolling the dice a little bit
and this is the thing that I wanted to
really study and you know kind of
reflect on over you know all of the
different products that we've built is
what were the patterns for the things
that we're successful are there ways
that we can tell as we are building
whether this is something that's that's
going to work or not and what came out
of that you know and a lot of
discussions and a lot of post mortems
and a lot of just looking at the things
that we had built was a framework of
just three simple questions at Facebook
that we now use to to ask ourselves
whether the things that we're building
feel like that they're on track and
there are three very simple questions
because you know it wasn't going to be a
manual that everybody was going to
memorize and understand but it's three
questions that we wanted everyone at
Facebook no matter what their role was
or what they worked on whether there
were engineers or designers or product
managers to keep in mind and you know
when they're having a team meeting or
whether we're reviewing the product or
whether you know they're actually just
talking with a colleague about an idea
to just think of these three questions
and to ask them and to make sure that we
have really really good answers to these
questions so that's what I'm going to
talk with you guys about today so the
first question is is the most basic and
the question is what people problem are
we trying to solve and the key word here
is is really the word people because of
course whenever we build anything we're
trying to solve the problem but what
tends to happen is like you start to
think in the mentality of your team or
your company and you start to say things
like you know the problem we need to
solve is that we need to optimize the
click-through rate of our page and you
know you'll hear things like this all
the time you know well down in in small
ways and in large ways and that's not a
people problem a people problem as we
define it is if you go out and you talk
to someone on the street and they were
to articulate a problem that they were
having that's how they would say it you
know that is the people problem
statement so there's a couple things
that we look at to make sure that you
know this is a valid people problem
statement the first is that it needs to
be a human and straightforward so we're
not using words like CTR we're not using
words like optimize or you know and
integrate like these are not words
people on the street would use you know
these are not words that people who are
outside of the tech community are going
to use to talk about their problems the
second thing is we want to make sure
that its solutions agnostic a lot of
times we start problems by saying I am
going to build an app that blank or I'm
going to design a website that blank and
already in that statement is is an
inkling of what the solution is but what
if you know apps not the right way or
what if it's not supposed to be a
website so a good people problem
statement gets away from you know trying
to already constrain it into a
particular solution the third thing is
that it shouldn't be about you know a
you know Facebook or your company or
your team or whatever winning and I
think classic example is if you say you
know our service is going to be the best
at blah blah blah a person on the street
doesn't care if your service is the one
that is the best at that they just want
to know hey for this problem that I have
what is the best solution
so stating any problem as like we you
know our team our company whatever wants
to win is is not getting close to the
things that people actually want the
fourth thing is that it gets at the why
so you know sometimes you might have a
problem like people aren't you know
discovering this page and that is a
problem that we need to solve but it
doesn't go one layer deeper it doesn't
get at well why you know what's actually
the root cause of why people aren't
discovering this page is it too hidden
for them is it too confusing for them to
find like it's got to get you know to
not just what is happening but what is
the reason why it's happening and
finally a good people problem statement
can not just you know solve functional
problems like like a confusing flow but
could also get at emotional or social
problems sometimes people just want to
feel like they belong sometimes people
just want to feel like they're validated
those are things that also constitute
you know something that that that when
you ask people they might they might say
so let's look at some examples so
earlier this year I had the privilege of
attending the moms 2.0 summit and this
is a gathering of a lot of influential
bloggers and journalists who you know
our mothers and who talked about you
know Parenthood and those topics and so
I got a chance to meet a lot of the
attendees and be on a panel with with
some of them and one of the things that
I heard over and over again was was
basically this and this is an example to
me of a people problem statement I want
to talk about an interest with other
people who are also interested but I
don't know where to find them and this
is especially relevant at this
conference because a lot of times what
would happen is you know you're a new
mom and baby you know you're in your
front and your friend group nobody else
is having babies around the same time as
you at the same time you know there's so
many things that goes through your mind
you want to know like is this normal my
baby just did this like should I be
worried you know what are some resources
you want to have like a community of
other new moms to be able to talk to you
and so a lot of times you know women
will will not know exactly where to find
that community and if they're lucky you
know friends or other people would say
hey there's you know a local you know a
group here or there's like a
neighborhood moms group but this is
something that a lot of people in the
audience were we're talking about is
something that that was a problem to
them so this is an example of a people
problem statement here's another example
this one we've heard over and over again
ever since we introduced the like button
on Facebook
everybody would ask why don't you guys
have a dislike button and that would be
one of the the top most requests that
we've had for for years and years but
you know that's not really a people
problem statement that's sort of just a
suggestion
we dig deeper the reason why people
wanted a dislike button is frankly
because not everything and news feed is
likable you know people write about part
times that they're going through
tragedies that are happening in their
lives you know recently we just went
through the selection which was very
very charged and you know people would
read things or say things that
made them feel a lot of different
emotions not just happy once and so that
is basically the people problem
statement not everything in feed is
likable and I want to be able to easily
express other things and finally one
more example so sometimes you know I
call these people problem statements
sometimes are not just problems in the
way of like hey you know someone going
to bring this up as like a hardship in
their life that they want solved
sometimes it's just more of an
opportunity or a thing that you know if
you ask people if they wanted they would
say yes an example here is the the
desire to share spontaneously and
authentically right a lot of times we're
going through you know a pretty cool
experience and we might capture it at
that moment and then an hour later go
and upload it on Facebook but you know
how cool it'd be to actually have that
experience live with our friends and our
family so that is an example of another
people problem statement so those are
basically you know the first the first
thing that we always ask is okay do we
have a like a statement that is really
about what problem we're trying to solve
for people that's the first question so
now the second question is well how do
we know this is a real problem and by no
I mean well what evidence do we have
right
is there qualitative evidence that it is
is there quantitative evidence that we
can look at and I highlight the word
real not because you know I think that
they're like fake problems but but just
because you know I think the question to
ask is is this a problem that is worth
solving you know all of us have limited
time energy resources money whatever to
be able to devote you know our our being
to trying to solve problems what makes
this one the one that we should pick out
of the thousands or ten millions of
problems that are out there and so this
question is really about just making
sure that the opportunity is is is
something that is worth tackling and
that we aren't just you know solving
problems for ourselves individually but
that we actually are very aware of the
problems that the audience that we're
building for is facing
so for the example of groups you know I
want to talk about I want to find other
people who are interested in discussing
the same things as I am the way that we
tried to validate whether or not this
was a big enough use case was of course
we went and we talked to a lot of people
but we also looked at some of the data
that we had so when we designed the
group's product to start with we
imagined that most of the time you know
you would get invited to the group so I
might start a book club and I'm going to
invite some of my friends who like
reading the same books as me and you
know that's how that's how we're all
going to know about the group so in our
initial formulation of groups it was
really all about you know being invited
by somebody else who was already a part
of this group but one of the things
actually that some of the engineers on
the group's team had hacked over the
years was this little unit called groups
you should join and so some of you guys
might have seen it sometimes you are
scrolling through your feed and you know
this little story will pop up and it
based on you know what your friends have
joined and groups in your community and
groups that are similar to things that
we think you might be interested in
you'll see some recommendations and and
you know you can go and explore them and
decide to join them if you want and you
know we thought that this was just a
small feature but really you know most
of the inviting was going to happen
through you know the normal invite
process but when we took a look at the
data what we found was that actually a
third you know of group memberships were
starting to happen via this little
groups you should join unit which meant
that there actually was a need and a
desire already using this the you know
tools that we currently had that people
wanted to find things that they weren't
explicitly being invited to that there
were examples of all sorts of things
that they wanted to be able to
participate in and see that they just
weren't getting connected to any other
way so this was I think good evidence
for us that if we wanted to devote
something you know a larger solution to
helping people discover groups that that
was a worthwhile endeavor we also talked
to a lot of people in a lot of different
groups one of the the folks who talked
to
this group called the physician mom's
group this is actually a one of the most
active groups on Facebook and I think
something like one out of four doctors
who are mothers in America are part of
this group and one of my friends
actually happens to be a doctor who just
had a baby and so you know she was lucky
enough to have one of her colleagues at
her to this group but she talked about
how meaningful it was to her and you
know she would spend hours on this group
every single week because you know these
doctor moms would be sharing tips on
kind of how to balance their work and
you know how to really tackle a lot of
the issues that come from being in that
profession and this is an example of you
know a group that that everyone who is a
part of it finds a hugely meaningful but
not everyone knows about it because like
how would you know that that this thing
even existed out in the world unless
somebody told you another example is you
know I recently you know attended our 10
year reunion and at the reunion a lot of
people were using groups to coordinate
events and meetups and the biggest
barrier is that like half of the people
that I talked to didn't know that these
groups existed that there was you know a
class of 2006 group and that there was a
reunion group and that there were you
know groups for different dorms and who
are planning their get-togethers and
finally you know there are a lot of
groups I'm a designer
and one of the the top groups that a lot
of designers in the community join is
this group called designers guild a lot
of designers share tools and articles
that they've read and other resources
and every time you know I happen to add
someone because I thought about them
that is that they might enjoy it they're
always like wow I didn't know about this
like that's the first thing that
everyone Waze says I didn't know about
this so all of this you know when we did
our focus groups in our research we was
more evidence that that in fact we
should be doing more to to help people
discover groups so we ended up doing was
actually building a pretty simple
discover feature if you go to your
group's tab right next to it there will
be a tab called discover and you know we
did our research on what works
I what were the topics that people were
most interested in so you can scroll
through you'll see suggestions based on
things that that you already are part of
but then you'll also be able to go and
browse by category and this is where you
can find you know parenting groups if
you're a photographer people to go you
know on the photo trips with on the
weekends or play sports with or you know
joining a running group and these are
all groups that are public and that
actually want to welcome new members for
the people problem of not everything
that I see in newsfeed is likeable and I
want to be able to express you know
other emotions we wanted to make sure
that this was actually a problem that
that you know many people faced and that
you know the solution that we had would
actually directly address it so we
looked at you know we talked to a lot of
users we had them go through their feeds
and describe to us you know for each
story what what was their reaction or
they feeling you know it's sort of like
free flow tell tell us what's going
through their minds as they're going
through their feet and you know a lot of
times people would say well there should
be more ways for me to just say
something because what I like about the
like button is that it's so simple you
know I don't have to you know go and
comment and the keyboard comes up and I
have to like you know two handedly type
something I like the fact that I can
just in one gesture how to scroll
through things and then you know say
that I like it but the only thing I can
do is like and there's got to be you
know other other ways for me to express
other emotions we also looked at will
help you how are people you know using
how are people expressing that they
don't like something today and we looked
at the stickers that people were using
and leaving us comments as well as the
emoji and what we're kind of the most
popular ones were you know how
frequently were people just leaving a
simple sticker or a simple emoji and
finally we looked at also short comments
so we looked at how many comments were
just one or two words and all they
expressed was like awesome or like that
sucks or you know a very very short
phrase that we felt we couldn't
encapsulate so with all that you know we
decided
we looked at all that data we looked at
what were the most common emotions that
people wanted to express and we just we
designed something that we felt was sort
of fulfilled that criteria of being
really really lightweight so you can
still do it with one hand in one gesture
it's not like multiple taps and we also
you know taking all of the data that we
had gotten from what were the most
common things that people you know the
common reactions that they had we just
we built the reactions product and so
you just scrub through and we took the
the top most what we couldn't want to do
to be universal reactions and that
that's the options that you see in that
tray and finally for the people problem
of I want to share spontaneously
authentically in the moment this was
interesting to us because you know we
had the Facebook live product out for
celebrities and we built it for
celebrities and public figures first
because when we talked to them that was
something that they told us very
directly that they wanted and it was
something that they were used to because
you know they live their lives in the
spotlight and they're they're very used
to going onto the red carpet and doing
interviews and you know being broadcast
live and it was something that they felt
they could do to kind of connect with
their fans a little bit more so this is
something that we had out that you know
they that were that was only available
to public figures but what the
interesting insight for us was well is
this something that that people want who
aren't public figures you know is this
something that people in the audience
you guys me you know all of us would
this be something that that non public
figures would use and find valuable and
that is the question that we set out to
try and uncover improve and actually one
of the easiest ways for us to do that
was to you know just build it for
ourselves you know we already had the
code that ran for public figures and we
just turned it on and we you know see if
anybody at the office uses it and what
their reactions were and we saw actually
a lot of really creative ways in which
people used it some people used it to
broadcast or team meetings you know for
people who are like working from home
a lot of times when our VC programs
weren't working super well the other
benefit is that you know you record the
video and then it's available afterwards
so for people who couldn't tune in live
they still had a chance to watch the
contents of the meeting we also sell
people just take it out for a weekend so
you know they'd go to brunch on Saturday
with their family and then they would go
live and then you know people would
chime in and there would be this
conversation and the people who did this
were like yeah it was awesome like I had
a great time and then we also saw people
you know taking it for you know a run so
so a team at Facebook was doing this
relay race and you know they wanted
other folks to kind of cheer them on and
give them support so they went live and
this is also like a super fun thing for
for them and for all the people who
participated so that was some inkling
that you know hey this could actually be
something that that other people wanted
and so what we did we just we launched
it to a small percentage of our users
you know as kind of a test to see if
there were there was interest in the
market and that was you know the
Facebook live product on Android it
launched on Android first and right away
we did see a lot of really really
creative uses so one woman you know who
is a tattoo artist was started to
broadcast live you know as she was in
the process of tattooing somebody we
also saw a woman who broadcasted her her
wedding live because she had family
members who couldn't make it and who
couldn't travel the long distance and
you know it was really really cool to be
able to see how she could engage and
interact with those audience members and
almost have it feel like you know there
were a part of that experience and you
know I had a lot of fun taking it out I
managed to get reservations to one of
the best restaurants in San Francisco
lazy bear and it's a really cool
experience because the chef stands up
there and he explains every single dish
and he kind of talks about you know all
of the love and care that went into you
know how this dish came together and I
just decided to go live and like a ton
of my friends tuned
and everybody's like I really want to go
to the restaurant too so so that was
really fun
okay so that brings us to the last
question so let's say we built this we
validated that it's something that
people want or we think you know there's
enough reason to believe that that it's
a you know something that is a real
problem and then that's something that
is worth solving so now we build it and
we put it out there but even actually
build for the thing is out in the world
in fact even before maybe we have a full
prototype the question for us to ask is
well how will we know if we've solved
this problem you know like what would
the what would be different in the world
what would you know if we fast forward
and now this thing that we've done is
out there how will we know if we should
be happy if we should be excited if we
think it's you know didn't live up to
our expectations what exactly should our
expectations be and I think this is a
really really important question to ask
up front too often what ends up
happening is we have this idea and then
we build it and we launch it into the
world and then results come in you know
we're looking at like the dashboards
we're looking at how many people are
downloading it and what they're saying
and you know there's tons of data points
that we're trying to you know interpret
and put together but it's hard at that
point in time to then be very very
objective about did we solve the problem
because a lot of you know our natural
inclination is to read into the good
things that people are saying and to
kind of consider all of that effort to
have been worth it right and that that
there's biases that kind of come from
when you know you're already looking at
data and you're trying to interpret
whether or not it's good or bad it's
much better before you launch to have
figure it out you know what constitutes
success for you so that you can you know
go into the launch with that
understanding and as a results come in
you can map it to your previous you know
this was my criteria for whether or not
we've solved the problem or whether this
was successful and so what we do here is
we want to make sure that we set
measurable goals and metrics and
measurable is really key
measurable doesn't always mean like
numbers or data but it does mean you
know there's a criteria where if I did
this thing and I got this result I know
what to make of that result so for the
example of groups I know we wanted to
help people solve the problem of helping
them find you know other people to talk
about their interest with we ended up
building a groups discover dashboard
what the success look like for us so
before we launched we determined that
well if we were successful at actually
helping people solve this problem we
would see that more people are then
discovering you know groups that they're
interested in and joining them but not
just joining because you know I could
make a giant button flash and make it
red and I'm sure more people would click
on it and more people join like that
doesn't really count right what really
matters is that they've joined these
groups and these groups are actually
meaningful to them which means that if
we you know fast forward a couple months
three months let's say and then we look
back these people are still using those
groups and they're actively engaging
meaning they're you know talking with
other people they're reading the content
they're sharing content they're liking
they're commenting you know we want to
know that people are joining groups that
are actually valuable for them and that
there's that they're spending time on so
that is actually the more important
metric was not just joins but meaningful
joints for the example of you know I
want to be able to quickly express my
feelings about a story but not
everything is likable you know we
launched reactions and prior to
launching reactions we wanted to make
sure we measured a couple of things if
we were successful here then what we
should see is that well people are using
these reactions and not just using them
you know it's not it's not good enough
if like all the people that were
previously you know using a sticker or
an emoji or a short comment then
converted to using reactions because
then it's just sort of a one-for-one
trade
right if reactions was actually more
lightweight we should see more people
using that than the previous set of
people who were using all of these other
tools so that was really important to us
so I was kind of the first thing that we
looked at the second thing we looked at
was we wanted to make sure that every
reaction did get a fair amount of usage
across different markets and this is
important to us because you know in the
beginning even when we started to design
reactions we had you know considered
lots of different options you know we've
considered you know maybe maybe you'd be
funny if you know you were like uh you
know you like an awesome button or you
know like like there's a tons of
different things that we could have put
in order to make it more expressive and
the reason why we distilled it back down
to six is because we wanted to make sure
that it was simple to use and if you
were going through and choosing from
like a grade of twenty suddenly it you
know it doesn't feel that my light
weight anymore it feels like you had
you're pulling up the interface and
you're choosing something and it's going
to take more than a couple taps to get
you to what you want so it's really
important that we nailed and got to a
really really small set but that we pick
the right set so we wanted to make sure
that these word universal and it wasn't
like you know people in certain
countries we're using you know certain
ones more or people in certain
demographics we're favoring others
because it was a nice thing we want to
make sure that these were actually
things that expressed you know emotions
people wanted to express in all of our
different countries and in all
demographics and then finally we wanted
to make sure that the experience was
good for the receiver so if you you know
posted something and then you got a
bunch of reactions you know did that
make you feel bad did that make you feel
confused you know was it you know like
did you not know what was it like going
on or did you just feel like it was a
negative experience and it made you want
to share less in the future that was
also really important and that was
actually one of the reasons why we never
straight up you know put a dislike
button because dislike and of itself can
be very ambiguous am i disliking the
content that you posted am i disliking
you as a
person am I just not agreeing with your
point of view and so you know in all of
our research and understanding it is
like we knew that it was something that
people were going to get confused by and
wasn't going to be a great experience so
when we launched reactions we similarly
wanted to make sure that that that
wasn't the case that the you know
emotions that were being expressed felt
like they were adding to the posters
understanding of what their friends and
and audience had to say and finally for
the example of I want to spontaneously
and authentically share in the moment
what we decided to measure and look at
was that you know of course people were
broadcasting but again it's not just did
they broadcast once because that's
something that you can you know make
happen by doing a ton of promotion and
by putting a front and center you know
if you just you know if people will try
a lot of things once because they don't
know what it is or they think it sounds
exciting
the true test for us was when they had a
live you know they went live and they
had that experience did they like it
enough to go and do it again you know
that is the key that tells us we build
something that is valuable and that's
worthwhile because people will come back
and do it again and do it again and and
you know they'll incorporate it and make
it a part of their lives the second
thing we looked at is we wanted to make
sure that well if you know maybe it'd be
fine if broadcasters loved it maybe you
know everybody wants to go live all the
time but is it really a good product if
nobody wants to watch you know what
people are broadcasting live right and
then it's sort of one-sided and over
time broadcasters are not going to want
to do that because nobody ever watches
anything we wanted to make sure that the
content was actually interesting and a
way that we could measure that was is
the time spent watching live videos
going up proportionally and you know
when we run surveys and other things are
people saying that this is like a
valuable thing that they want to watch
so to recap I one of those kind of the
three questions that we always ask in
product reviews and you know anytime
we're talking about products we want to
make sure that we
we know what people problem we're trying
to solve that it's very clearly defined
that we can picture you know the
audience or a particular person in mind
as we're designing the product and that
we're not solving you know problems for
ourselves or our company or our team but
that were actually you know focused on
an audience that in a problem that
matters for them the second thing is
just making sure that we know it's a
real problem you know through looking at
whatever quantitative data we have
through doing focus groups and talking
to different users understanding that
this is something that that is a good
use of time for us to work on and to
solve and finally being very very
rigorous about what does success look
like and how will we know if you know we
put something out there and it did what
we wanted it to do
and if not then we go back to the
drawing board we learn what didn't work
and we keep iterating but these three
questions have helped keep our teams
focused on what matters which is
ultimately the people that we design for
so that's it for this presentation and I
think we've got plenty of time for
questions
[Applause]
yes hi there so there are studies that
show that the use of Facebook is I often
linked to low self-esteem and sometimes
the press runs and people so I was
wondering if I'm like a product science
standpoint history team doing a needs
like address was negative yes so the
question was you know the studies
started do you know which studies in
particular mentioned any in particular
that they say like Journal of Social and
Clinical Psychology has made
publications on so the question is you
know is this Facebook lead to people
being lonely or lower self esteem and
what are we doing to address that in the
product so this is something that I
think is really interesting to us
because you know we've hear a lot of you
know concerns around like is the product
you know good for for people is it
something that's helpful is it you know
taking away from them and in all the
studies that we've been able to do and
that we partnered with you know a lot of
institutions to work on I think that
they're that I think it goes both ways
so there's a lot of you know studies
that sort of show that it's actually
better and that it helps connect you
with weak ties which helps you get more
you know understanding of you know
diversity and other things in the world
and other times where people who go
through difficult experiences are able
to get support from the people in their
network certainly I think that there is
also things where you know maybe some of
you guys who experienced the idea of
like fear of missing out where you see
other people you know having these great
experiences and it makes you wonder
about like your life so all in all I
don't think there's conclusive evidence
as you know and this is something that
we have studied the where it's like it's
either drastically better for the world
or drastically worse for the world what
we do believe in is that you know by
being connected to people and by being
able to share with the world that that
is something that is worth you know
doing that's a huge human and and
universal need and that's something that
we believe fair
in terms of other things that we have
done there's there are problems on
Facebook that that we know are very
difficult things like bullying you know
or even just more commonly breakups
these are things where you know because
of the the the fact that people are
using Facebook especially for things
like breakups you know you used to you
know there's tons of photos of you and
this other person and there's you know
you're constantly seeing posts from this
other person because when you guys were
together in a relationship you know we
knew that this was an important person
to you and after a breakup which is a
one-time event you know what we heard
from a lot of people that that's
actually a terrible experience right you
don't want to go into Facebook and see
news feed stories from this person a lot
of times you don't you know you don't
want to see photos of this person you
just don't actually in certain cases
want to have any interaction with those
people and that is actually an example
of a problem that we thought was really
meaningful and something worth
addressing even though it doesn't affect
like everyone in the room every day it
was something that when it happens is
difficult enough that we wanted to be
able to you know put a solution around
so we launched a feature called breakup
checkup earlier this year and so after
you say you're no longer in a
relationship with somebody we want to
make you aware of the tools that are
available for you to control your
content and control your privacy with
that person so that's an example of
something where you know looking at the
common you know things that people go
through that are just a part of life you
know how can we make that a little bit
better and a little bit easier on
Facebook
I think bullying is another one that we
care very very deeply about and want to
make sure that we have the right tools
to immediately be able to flag and to
you know take down and to also make you
aware of your options to block people so
that you don't have to keep interacting
with them on Facebook question
what has been your favorite product
you've been a part of the same what has
been my favorite product that I have
designed at Facebook I think that's a
really really difficult one I think for
me it's probably newsfeed and the reason
why I think newsfeed is so interesting
it has a I think just a really
interesting origin story which is that
you know when it launched some of you
may be aware of this but it was actually
one of the the least popular products
ever and this was back in 2006
you know I'd only been at Facebook for a
couple months and the origin for
newsfeed is that you know for all of us
who are using Facebook every day we were
following the same pattern we would go
open Facebook and we would check the
profiles of our 10 best friends so we'd
go and see you know what did Jane do
today and when she had anything new okay
no let's go Sam wouldn't you know did he
add any photos and this was our pattern
like every single day and that was a
little bit inefficient so we thought
well what if we didn't make you look you
know anywhere what if we just landed on
Facebook and we told you if Jane had a
you know updated her photos and if Sam
had like you know changed what his
favorite band was and and we'll just
save everyone a lot of work and so we
were like very very excited about this
feature we loved it we thought it was
like amazing and we put it out there and
people hated it like like I can't even
describe how much light you know at the
time Facebook was a college and high
school site and I think about 10% joined
a group called I F and hate Facebook
newsfeed and and at the time you know it
Facebook wasn't like a big news right
you know Peet outlets you know like CNN
or a major media outlets like never
wrote about Facebook because it was just
you know college site but at that moment
it was such a funny story that so many
you know people hated this feature that
they started reporting on that just like
haha there's a site out there that you
know a lot of college kids use and then
they launch this feature and like oh my
gosh was there like you know a huge
uprising and like they did a terrible
job so it was like our first like major
wave of
you know oppressor from major media
outlets but what was interesting is that
you know for us we started to look at
like well did we really mess up is this
something that's actually truly awful
like you know is everything that we
believed in wrong and the things that
that we're interesting is that even
though people you know join these groups
and told us all of these things that
they didn't like they were using it like
they were using news feed the only
reason people haven't knew about the
group if' and hate Facebook newsfeed is
because it showed up in their newsfeed
and then they went and checked it out
and then they joined it so you know we
we listen to you know what were the
actual concerns and a lot of the
concerns were around you know I want to
have greater controls around which
things do get published into news feed
in which things don't so we heard those
concerns and we made those modifications
to our feature but it was because we
were looking at you know the signs that
that there were some things that were
working there were things that we wanted
to you know improve as well that led us
to not just completely scrapped the
product despite the the backlash and
what I think has also been so
interesting about newsfeed for me is
that it's it's not just a one time
feature right it's not just like we put
it out there and we're like cool good
good job like we're done newsfeed is
probably one of the most iterated on
products over the years and you know
everything from the ranking and that you
know an algorithm and like how we
present information and the design of
stories you know especially as cell
phones got better and photos got more
high-res and now we were able to take
videos so to me what I've loved about
that process is it's it's an evolution
and it's you know never something that
kind of stays still and we can say it's
done it's something that we were
constantly thinking about and we're
constantly you know trying to make
better and better a question over there
yes I mash undergrads right here I'm
interested in democracy in tech um so
one of the norms really vital to a
functioning democracy is the commitment
to reason facts and
analysis and recently Facebook has
received a lot of criticism regarding
the proliferation of echo chambers and
misinformation what is your perspective
on Facebook's role in the election and
politics and in our democracy at large
and second how are you going to quite at
your chambers and misinformation
Facebook yeah so this is you know I
think with the recent election I think
it's been a pretty charged time a lot of
people have expressed a lot of oh sorry
yes I will repeat the question so the
question is around echo chambers and
filter bubbles and what is Facebook's
role in that and and what do we want to
do about it going forward is that sorry
okay
so I think you know given the election
which I'm sure is something that a lot
of us in this room are thinking about
you know we know that that's been a
really emotional time for a lot of
people and that there's a lot of you
know different thoughts and emotions and
and other things that people are feeling
around you know what is led to this day
that we're in and how can we move
forward mark you know had a statement
about this that he shared last week and
that you know of all of the news on
Facebook we do know that a very very
small percent less than 1% is what you
know be considered fake or misleading
news that said we don't think any of
that content should be on Facebook
because that's not helpful for people
nobody you know wants to go and read a
story that is obviously a hoax or is
spam so that's something that is
important for us and that we will
continue to work on that said one of the
things that Mark also talked about was
just how important it is that you know
even despite this this time where
there's a lot of emotions and and sort
of charge debate going on that you know
it's not we Facebook is not you know we
have to be very very careful about
whether or not we are censoring anything
or trying to push a particular point of
view and I think this is a you know a
super gray area that's very important
it's not we don't want to be a place
where you know people feel like there's
a particular point of view that is being
pushed on in facebook
and that's really really critical to us
and that's something that we're looking
at deeply and and wanting to make sure
that we're taking very careful steps
forward a question in the middle over
here yes a Facebook has been investing a
lot in oculus and Virtual Reality I'm
just wondering what your opinion of what
this is trying to solve the question is
around virtual reality and our
investment Facebook's been working a lot
in virtual reality what problem is that
trying to solve so I can't speak to this
a ton because I don't work on a lot of
the virtual reality products but you
know in the past Mark has talked about
his excitement for virtual reality as a
new medium that is that that he thinks
will enable people to be able to
communicate and share and is in line
with our mission of making the world
more open and connected and the way that
we think about it is you know when we
started Facebook the medium that we were
all using was the desktop website right
you know mobile phones weren't a big
thing everybody was like using Facebook
on desktop but as technology shifts and
as it was really clear that you know
mobile phones were here to stay and they
were efficient and we could you know do
a lot of things on them that you know we
had to adapt Facebook our site and our
services to the mobile phone and in a
lot of ways you know in the future I
think virtual reality as an as a new
medium is really really exciting there's
tons of things that you know we'll be
able to explore and design and think
about in that medium that weren't able
to we weren't able to do with desktop
computers or with mobile phones but all
of the things that we're going to do
there are I think going to be in the
same vein aligned with the mission of
trying to help people be connected and
to be able to share questions from the
back yes can you share some examples in
which a problem or an idea bus the bus
system like you would not qualify at all
you could not figure out how to measure
and pens and did not go yes
are there any examples of the questions
are there examples of problems we've
looked at that I've passed the first
test so it's a real people problem but
that you know we didn't have enough
evidence was a real enough problem for
us to go and tackle I think that yeah
absolutely in fact a lot more of that
then actually the things that we end up
building you know I think we have this
you know program at Facebook that that a
lot of people participate in which is
called hackathons right and so the idea
is that you you know we'll run these
every six weeks or so and everyone at
the company who has an idea that they're
excited about and want a hack on you
know they spend the night it's usually
one night or perhaps you know one night
in one day and they form teams with
other people at Facebook and then they
just build that product and then you
know they then we have this you know big
thing called the heck of a hackathon
Fair where a lot of people kind of weigh
in and there's judges and people present
their products and then you know we
figure out whether these are things that
we actually want to kick off and build
or or to test or to actually make
available in the products and I think
there's a lot of projects you know
usually start around the idea of like
hey I would like this feature you know I
would like I would like to see here's
one example of something that we that
that kind of came about a long time ago
I would love to see really immersive
large photos you know for Facebook right
I have a really large screen and I've
got a lot of computing power and all the
Facebook stories look really small so
let's try and you know make everything a
little bit richer and a little bit more
visual and let's do that and so we
actually you know tried that we built
that but what we learned was that you
know that's true for us here in Silicon
Valley you know we have the
top-of-the-line machines and you know we
are able to you know have really fast
broadband access so we can load really
really big images but that just wasn't
true
many many parts of the world so when we
did that you know we actually made the
experience of people in those areas
worse because they had to wait longer
and things just didn't like fit as well
and and it wasn't a great experience for
them so that's something that we end up
not shipping because it didn't sort of
satisfy that like didn't you know was
this a big problem for everyone alright
last question question over here in the
middle he's costing our introduction
about interning at Facebook number one
hundred gate role what practical advice
do you have for us from evaluating oh I
didn't catch last right watch it
practical advice you have for us we were
like evaluating John steps so the
question is what practical advice do I
have for people who are evaluating job
offers for startups I think the most
important thing is whether or not this
is a group of people that you love to
work with and that youth you know you
can see yourself being able to learn
from and you know work with and they
share the values that you care about the
most I think that that's the first thing
I would look at and I think the second
thing I would look at is whether or not
the the thing that the company is trying
to do resonates with what you care about
so you know every startup out there
every company out there is trying to
solve a particular set of problems and
some of these problems are going to you
know be more meaningful for you than
others and so I think those were the two
questions that I don't ask you know do
you feel like this is something that you
would be excited to wake up every day
and work on because it's doing something
that you believe in and are you going to
be able to do it with the people that
you really respect and look up to and
and who feel the same way about you cool
thank you guys thank you very much
[Applause]